un outil technologique pour préserver
l'environnement dans les forêts
yvelinoise l'objet de la convention
vigilance environnement signé par l'état
le département la gendarmerie l'office
national des forêts et l'office français
de la biodiversité une application
gouvernementale de mise en réseau
baptisé chap
les techniciens de terrain de l'office
national des forêts sont avec ce réseau
social privé fermées pour protéger et
l'utilisent pour échanger avec les
gendarmes avec l'office français de la
biodiversité avec les écogardes pour
signaler un problème et permettre aux
forces de l'ordre d'intervenir si c'est
nécessaire
ce réseau sécurisé et facilite les
échanges entre les différents acteurs
objectif lutter contre les incivilités
en forêt comme les dépôts d'ordures
sauvages de chantier ou encore d'autres
activités allusive une zone d'opération
pour la gendarmerie des yvelines cas d
action purement opérationnel ou sur la
base d'un renseignement qui ne sont
fournies par ces agents dont l'agent un
mot il peut intervenir très rapidement
et puis il ya également des actions de
formation qu'il s'agit de se former
mutuellement sur les 1 les spécificités
administratives ou techniques et d'autre
ce qu'on peut faire en termes de
prérogatives judiciaires qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir entre guillemets des
mesures de police et donc une une
coopération entre tous les acteurs de la
protection de l'environnement
les trois quarts des yvelines sont des
espaces ou agricoles boisé c'est une
richesse exceptionnelle dans un
territoire qui est réputé être urbain
puisque nous sommes la région parisienne
dans le département des yvelines la
surface boisée représentent près de 70
mille hectares soit 30 % de la surface
totale du territoire